[Music]
do one more why not hi papoom I'm gonna
talk about CSS pranks J's Kampf I know
but CSS pranks you used to I don't even
know if I'll need the whole five minutes
here they used to be a really cool way
that you could do this in Chrome there
was a file called custom CSS and if you
open that file and you put CSS in it it
would apply that CSS to every single
website that this person went to which
was an awesome way to just kind of mess
with them and mangle with them but that
was eventually deprecated but you can
now pretty much build a small extension
add to CSS into it install the extension
on anybody who's really kind of
unsuspecting and if they've just left
that computer open you can kind of do
that it used to be funnier because in
custom CSS it would apply to all the
settings and everything like that in the
browser so sometimes it was really
confusing to kind of turn things off but
yeah so once you kind of enter this
point where you can enter CSS into
anybody's page you can really start to
kind of mess with some people so here's
a really really simple example if you
put grayscale 100% on everything
everybody's websites are gonna be black
and white and it's just every single
thing you're looking at Google Images
anything like that it's black and white
and the key I think to messing with
people is subtle [ __ ] rather than
full-blown unusable 'ti if you rotate
the page just by a tiny tiny amount it's
gonna look normal at the start this is
my old website but as they start to
scroll down it's gonna start to get
weirder and weirder where here's my my
current website for example you can do
that to every single website that
somebody visits and they're just I guess
you just gotta kind of start to tilt
your head something like that this is
another kind of funny one is it's kind
of trying to take advantage of class
names that are used by a lot of websites
so here's a keyframe animation that will
that will spin something if you apply
that to the class logo the ID logo logo
images logo image
every site is not gonna start to have a
logo that kind of spins around here's
code pen
yeah there's Google if you do this to
somebody again it doesn't really give
them enough reason to think what's going
on here I need to fix this so just say
have you notice the logo of spinning on
a lot of websites it's just a trend just
a design trend yeah you can change every
every link make it hot pink there's
there's TweetDeck another one odds for
breast cancer who doesn't even yeah
there we go this is this is something
that you can do that's kind of really
messing is make a keyframe animation
that rotates the hue of things so when
you do that this is just an image you
can kind of start to see that it really
slowly changes in tones and that'll be
every women on every website that these
people go to and if you really want to
mess with them cleverly you make it over
a minute long the animation so it's just
really not something they kind of notice
but you you can tell it really messes
with their braids just make every
transition really really slow on every
page make it important if they're doing
any animations everything that's going
to run for three seconds and then you
can mess with just like obnoxious just
CSS that I kind of showed in my talk you
can just have all their fonts kind of go
crazy but you will actually send
somebody insane by doing that that's all
I have to say thank you
[Applause]